Hi, I'm Chet Haase,
an engineer on the
Android team at Google.
I work on graphics and
animation, but today, I'm
going to talk about something
a little bit different.
Little bit of animation,
but it's more about
doing things wrong.
So this is the first in possibly
an ongoing series
which I like to call You're
Doing It Wrong.
So the demo I'm going to show
you today, this is really
hacked up, as many of my demos
are, and very obvious, and you
may not do things exactly
this way.
But these are examples taken
from real apps shipping on the
device, where we've seen
approaches like this or like
this in a maybe much more
complex and not as
obviously bad way.
So it's important to sort of
take the main idea away from
it, if not the exact
implementation.
So in particular, I want to look
at ListView and the idea
that there's a distinction
between the position of items
on the screen and the views that
represent the content in
those items.
And you should understand
those differences very
carefully for the following
reason.
So let's take a look at
the demo, which I call
ListViewDeletion.
And we've got a list of
cheeses on the screen.
We can select several of these,
and we want to select
the ones that we're getting
rid of, so we
click the Delete Selected.
They fade out, so that's the
animation part of this thing.
They fade out, and then we
remove them from the adapter.
And the ListView updates, and
all things are wonderful.
But what happens if we select
a few of these, and then we
scroll down and, OK, we'll go
ahead and run the deletion.
OK, let's run that one again.
If I could slow-mo
this, I would.
Notice that there are things
fading out on the screen that
had nothing to do with the
ones that are checked.
In fact, if I scroll all the
checked ones off the screen,
nothing should fade out because
none of these items
are actually selected.
So they shouldn't be removed,
but they are.
But actually, the content of
the items themselves is not
being deleted.
What's being deleted
are the views.
So we fade out the view, and
then we delete the items.
Well, the items that are being
deleted are not the views that
are being faded out.
So what's going on?
So there's a concept in ListView
of view recycling.
This is done because you can
have ListViews of enormous
size with tons of views in them,
and we don't want to
instantiate all of those
things and have them
persistent in the state of the
activity at all times, and we
don't want to have to update all
this stuff every time we
redraw the ListView.
So instead, we have active views
for the items that are
on the screen at the time.
And as views scroll off, those
views get recycled and used
for other content
on the screen.
It's very nice.
It makes ListView very smooth to
fling and to scroll and to
interact with.
However, it means that if you
are assuming things about the
specific views that are being
used in a ListView, you're
doing it wrong.
It's important to understand
that ListView--
you should really think of it
as a holder of content, and
that you need to really interact
with that content in
terms of the adapter directly
and not necessarily the views
on the screen, or else
you at least need to
know what you're doing.
So let's take a look at the
code and see what the
application is doing wrong.
So we have this ListViewDeletion
class.
We create this array list
holding this large list of
cheeses, terribly interesting
content.
And then we have this set
on Click Listener
for the Delete Button.
So when you click the button, it
figures out what to delete
and runs animations and removes
things appropriately.
And then there's some code
down here where, when you
actually checked on these
things so we can
take a look at that.
On Item Click Listener for the
check box, it basically adds
these views to this list
of checked views there.
So we track that.
Now, this is kind of the hack
part of the demo, where we're
actually tracking the views
that are actually being
deleted for the purposes
of the demo.
So we go through here, and we
go through the checked items
of the ListView.
And this is the default code,
which is bad, which is--
OK, this check box to control
the behavior is not currently
checked, so we're going to run
the code that we thought was
obvious, and we're
going to fade out
views and remove them.
So first of all, we're going to
post this delayed thing to
actually remove it from the
adapter after the fade
animation is done.
We know that the animation
is going to take 300
milliseconds.
The actual animation is run down
here, where we iterate
through the checked
views list.
And for each one of those,
we grab the view that was
checked, and we run an
animation on it.
This is using the view property
animator API, which
was introduced in
the 3.2 release.
So we say animate the alpha
property to 0, and when you
finish, let's restore the alpha
property because that's
good practice.
Otherwise, the thing
stays invisible.
So all of that looks good except
for the part where, if
you scrolled off the screen,
that view got recycled and
reused by completely
different content.
So now we're going to fade out
the view, which has nothing to
do with the content that was
checked, which is now sitting
off the screen.
Bad way to go.
If we go back and look at the
demo again, and we say Use
Positions instead of Use Views,
and we check a bunch of
things on here, and then we
run this thing, well, of
course, it does the right thing
when they're on the
screen anyway.
But if we scroll these things
off the screen, then it fades
out only the ones that are
actually selected that are on
the screen.
And that logic works
as follows.
So in here, we go into
the else clause.
First of all, we clear this
thing so that we're not going
to run animations on these
because we have a different
way of managing our animations
in this approach.
We get the position on the
screen, so we can get the
first visible position, and then
everything after that is
numbered after that position.
So we can say, OK, this is the
first visible position, and
then we iterate through
it, so this is the
number of checked items.
So we're actually iterating
through the
ListView items here.
So we can get the position of
the ListView item itself, the
position of the first visible
position, and then figure out
whether that thing is
actually on screen.
And if it's not on screen, don't
run an animation at all.
Just remove the thing.
In fact, we should remove it
after we're done so that it
doesn't blink the list and move
stuff around at the time.
But we basically use that as a
trigger to determine whether
it's on screen, therefore run an
animation on the thing, or
it's off screen, don't bother
with the animation, just
remove it when all the
animations are done.
So if it is on screen, then we
do a similar animation as we
did before.
We animate the alpha property
on that view with an End
action to restore alpha, and
after we've restored alpha,
then we remove it from
the adapter.
So all the animation code,
before it was good.
What wasn't good was that we
were using a view that was
determined at check time, not
at the time when we were
actually telling the system to
delete, and we knew what was
actually on the screen
at the time.
So the takeaway here is be aware
of the position of your
items on the screen, be aware
that your views can be
recycled, and be aware that
there is a really large
disconnect, potentially, between
those positions and
the views and the data
underneath that the views
happen to be displaying
at any point in time.
So thanks.